Haiti, explained like you are five.
In 1791, Haiti is called Saint-Domingue.
It belongs to France.
It is the richest colony in the world,
more sugar and coffee than every British colony combined.
It runs on half a million enslaved people.
In 1791, they revolt, not a riot, a revolution.
They defeat the French.
They defeat the British.
They defeat Napoleon's army,
the same army that took Europe.
In 1804, they win.
Haiti becomes the first nation on earth
built by people who freed themselves.
21 years later, French warships arrive, 14 of them,
guns pointed at the coast.
France has a demand, pay us for what we lost,
the plantations, the ships, and the people.
France wants to be paid for the humans
who freed themselves, 150 million francs.
10 times everything Haiti earns in a year.
Haiti has no Navy.
Haiti has no allies.
No country will trade with it.
Haiti says yes.
It borrows the money from French banks to pay France.
Haiti pays.
It pays through the 1800s.
It pays while it builds no schools.
It pays while it builds no roads.
It pays through an American occupation.
It pays for 122 years.
The last payment is sent in 1947.
Today, Haiti is the poorest country in the Western hemisphere.
It was never conquered.
It was invoiced.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers,
addictive, smart, surprisingly fun.
Try it now and become the most intelligent person
in the room.